ich empfinde diese bilder auch wirklich
als verstörend dass sowas überhaupt 2021
so passieren kann
sie sehen jetzt auch noch im bilde
unserem bild chef julian reichelt julian
wie ordnet du diese bilder die wir jetzt
aus moskau aussehen ein
ich muss erst einmal sagen dass ich
tatsächlich deutsch bin auf die
großartige reporter leistung unserer
kollegen peter tiede und fabian
matzerath dort moskaus der welt
tatsächlich live vor augen führen und
was für ein regime es sich in russland
handelt dass es sich um so ein regime
handelt da muss ich sagen bin ich nicht
besonders überraschend von ich habe
ehrlich gestanden in den letzten wochen
nicht wirklich nachvollziehen können
warum als einer weile jetzt schon diesen
schritt in dieses gigantische risiken
eingeht sein kalkül dahinter
das hat er ja ganz bewusst auch zum
eigenen schutz nicht geteilt ob er davon
ausgegangen ist dass er durch diesen
weltruhm zu dem er ja durch diesen
feigen mordanschlag dass putin regimes
finanziert übrigens mit dem geld mit dem
auch gerade eine pipeline nach
deutschland gebaut wird
ob man durch den welt diesen weltruhm
motiviert war nach russland zu gehen ob
er sich dadurch sicher und geschützt
gefühlt hat das waren alles gedanken wir
weitestgehend für sich behalten hat die
auch in dem interview mit dem dass wir
mit ihnen geführt haben nicht ausgeführt
hat er damals schon angekündigt ja er
geht zurück nach los
wo soll ich sonst hin ich bin größer ich
gehöre nach russland aber tatsächlich
ist das was heute abend bei uns live zu
sehen war für mich nicht überraschend
peter hat das ja auch angedeutet wie
dieses regime tickt ja wie skrupellos
dieses regime ist dieses gefühl dass
werden die ja wohl nicht bringen
das ist keine kategorie in der dieses
regime denkt putin ist in einer in einer
mörder organisation muss man ganz klar
sagen groß geworden dem kgb und dieser
organisation die
auch die in der zeit der deutschen
teilung im osten unseres landes für
angst und schrecken gesorgt hat diese
organisation hat er perfektioniert und
sind 21 jahrhundert übertragen und da
wird mit oppositionellen mit gegnern mit
wieder sachen eben genauso umgesprungen
wie das jetzt gerade passiert ist
insofern bitter ja ein schwarzer tag für
alle menschen die freiheit lieben ja
eine überraschung nein ganz sicher nicht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren